you have been uh directing films for
many years now do you find that the
physical demands of directing at all are
catching up with you well it's it
requires so much energy it requires so
much Focus that's that's the thing on
this picture that's why I didn't really
that Leo had to try to convince me of a
period of four or five years because I
knew I'd get into that energy level with
the actors and uh then I'd have to live
with it also in the editing because of
the structuring the editing with with
thus goodaker my editor you know for
like almost a year uh all the
improvisations and cutting and that sort
of thing and you have to really be uh in
that mode you have to really constantly
think that way like push the picture and
try F try for new um uh new structural
elements new narrative ways going very
fast and slowing down for long dialogue
scene and letting the actor's energy
pick it up all that sort of thing uh and
I I said I don't think I could survive
it but what happened was that what gets
worse is actually on the set is when I
arrive on the set these past I'd say 10
years or so I I found that now when I
get to the Set uh you know I'm
short and didn't notice no I am falling
out of this chair right now I mean I'm
really short uh and the thing about it
is that by the time I get on the set the
crew is there they're great guys
everybody working together but I can't
see
anything I I keep bumping into the
people I literally so now I the past
eight years or so I've had assistance
just their only their only job is to
take me through so I put my head down
put my hands on their shoulders
seriously the cables every here it's
nice and clean this is very nice but
ca's everywhere and you never know where
you're going to be you're bumping into
guys sorry your head's down your hand is
on someone else and you're walking along
absolutely absolutely the guys this is
giving me ideas I want to do this from
now on you I will go to the sex take
me that's exactly I go off I just go on
my way there's no more thank you there's
no more of that because I just got to
get there guys and then they take me I
said okay maybe they'll take me to the
monitor where I can see the shot but
then I have to get to the actors that's
another trip right and when I did youo
the actors were very small couldn't find
them geez how did that happen where they
where the kids what happened they're
right in front of you oh you know yeah
yeah oh and it's exhausting for that
sudden they workout Ways work out little
pads and and things like that right you
know that's it's uh it's funny because I
I think you've been uh visiting our show
we've been on for 20 years and your
energy level has not changed you have so
you have the same f and energy and drive
I don't you think so Andy you haven't
lost a step so I I you know I get a lot
of it from uh uh as I said the actors
are just on all the time I mean they're
just amazing uh but I really picked up
especially in the mornings I'm not a
very good morning person so on this
picture and you know the scenes in this
picture I mean to get there like 7:30 or
something like that I had ask what's
going to happen today oh God you know
and then I was just afraid of it because
I I had to come up to that level but the
minute I'd see Jonah or Leo come in and
start talking and moving and and that
that's what carried me through and then
like at lunchtime bang collapse and pick
up
again don't see the rushes because I
don't know what's going completely tired
see rushes at this point you know there
was uh when the film first came out some
people there was some controversy in the
press that people thought this is drug
it's it's a movie with uh a good deal of
drug taking in it but it's also there's
a lot of Comedy is this glamorizing uh
drug drug taking how did you feel about
that at the time about that well I mean
I I've over the years going back to Mean
Streets actually mean streets and uh
Raging Bull uh uh particularly good
Fellas I had the same argument really
same discussion people were concerned
Good Fellas was as if it was glamorizing
the life as if they didn't watch the
last hour of the picture yeah everybody
you know it's like they just watched the
first hour first half hour of the film I
the guys are being killed people are
being thrown in jail people so you know
the reality here was like uh let's take
that and let's show I mean if there's
such an indecency about the way they
behaved about money and what they've
done to people uh and and lying and
cheating and stealing and uh uh there's
such indecency then the picture should
be that way yeah the film should be that
way it should reflect that state of mind
and put you be like 40 minutes into the
picture you realize you're in this world
with these people and you're laughing
with them and maybe the laughter catches
by the end of the film in a way and
that's the main thing is that the
temptation of power uh is there and it's
always pleasurable so you want let's
show the pleasure because if we deny it
you know uh it it won't go away